Tick Tock vlogger Jessica who went viral
over the past a few days after posting a
video to her 600 000 plus followers
revealing the purported sexual
harassment that she encountered at the
gym
she also posted the video to Twitter
along with this caption this is our
caption she said this guy kept making me
extremely uncomfortable at the gym this
is why I'll end up crying on stream
because I feel so grossed out at times
with the amount of sexualization I
experienced in the thread below the
video she further explains that this man
was staring at her for quote
disturbingly long periods and that this
triggered her quote fight or flight
response and conjured up memories of
quote previous traumas excuse me
you don't have to do that it's okay no
no it's okay I got it thank you though
ah okay he glances over in her Direction
a few times and then finally walks over
and tries to help her put the weights on
the bar and she declines his help and he
says okay
and then he walks away the end